hey there ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to a very special episode of the
lobby it's our gamescom microsoft press
conference breakdown extravaganza and
I'm your host Chris waters joining me on
the couch to talk about the biggest
games from microsoft's press conference
in cologne germany Alex new house hey
alexa ray corriea home and Justin hey
Walt live from Germany we're not like
Germany this is we haven't transport of
the set to Germany uh we have
transported some gamespot people to
Germany it's not us no no but we were
all here watching the press conference
early this morning and we've got some
thoughts about the games we saw because
there are some pretty cool games that
they showed off and we got some extended
looks at games that we've been wanting
to see more of one of the games we've
been wanting to see more of least from
my perspective is quantum break so let's
start right there and they started off
with like just name-dropping just like
drop in shawn ashmore Aidan Gillen
little finger little finger I prefer
Carcetti but it you know you gotta
dominic monaghan so like really sort of
leaning into that fact like hey we've
got stars in here we're connecting this
to the TV show guys and it a bit it's
hard to be excited about a TV show for a
video game because we've seen not a lot
of great ones I mean it always feels
like this is going to be something
that's tacked on but this is one time
when I I'm really excited for the show
like it looked really good it's like all
these characters from lost and the story
seems really interesting like the other
trailers have been leading up to this
and like I it's ok but like now watching
it in action and like this weird time
travel story it's like fringe meets lost
meets like I'm really excited to learn
more about this world and I think we're
living in a world where like Netflix
originals amazon originals you're seeing
like a diverse kind of production
quality of TV it's not just some network
shows and HBO making the best TV out
there like there is a lot of creative
talent being poured into a lot of
different channels hopefully this ends
up being one of them and when they were
talking about this game though they were
talking about it in a way that made it
sound like it was integrated into the
game that it wasn't really a standalone
TV show um I don't know if we've heard
anything more about that but well we
haven't when they announced it they
initially were saying that there are
going to be elements of the TV show that
like the TV show will air and it will be
something wrong
we'll be able to play the game i think
they are initially announced it is
episodic I don't think that's I don't
know if that's the case anymore I can
imagine there would be sort of episodic
content you know you think to like halo
4 had episodic content that came out and
told bits of a story so it's not hard to
imagine you know we they they time it
and that was timed weekly so you know if
they have weekly episodes airing of the
show then you have a weekly episode
maybe to play maybe it's like a DLC size
kind of thing it's a smaller mission but
you know the larger game itself larger
narrative is is a much more robust
experience yeah the sense i got of it
was something like halo 4 Spartan Ops
where you have like the you know the CGI
in this case would be live action you
know video going into then a short
gameplay mission that you would play
each week and so we did see some
gameplay actually here we're taking a
look at exploring the space where one of
the first time it's for the first sort
of time travel machine was built and
it's doing this neat thing that I really
like I think is very cool is the sort of
playing through what like skipping
through different points in time it's a
sort of visually speed through this this
history of this project and but the
interesting thing was seeing this
actually happen in gameplay like you
know I assume what we're notching now is
more like not a cinematic that this is
something that's just telling this story
anyone when they were showing gameplay
if it's if it's anything like that and I
really hope that the game does look like
this that it's not kind of one of those
BioShock Infinite moments when it's like
here's an idea of what they aim is gonna
be like but it doesn't quite pan out
because what it seemed like is like
you're at you're changing time while
you're playing you're gonna throw on a
time bomb in like this area of the game
these people will be frozen and you'll
be able to fight that like you guys were
able to manipulate that and not be
affected by it until you rip out their
taunton going mini time travel devices
and they freeze in mid air around you
like that that look really cool yeah I
really like the gameplay we're seeing
it's sort of it I don't know I don't
know that we've seen anything really
like this where you can still release
top stuff and then go after people maybe
sort of seem there's been some time
dabbling in shooters before first-person
shooters like time shift and others but
this is I mean this like the time thing
is what elevates this above another
third person shooter right like cuz I
mean he was in cover and he was like
running around it kind of has a vaguely
uncharted look to it it's otherwise it's
very standard like Oh Gibby hunt cover
dodge guys you can see where the bullets
are coming
mm-hmm what I was thinking that was like
you know it does look very powerful this
time ability which actually in a sense
contextualizes why you're this one one
man army in a sense you know what a lot
of games you are just one guy going
through you know murdering tons and tons
of soldiers but in this you actually
have some sort of story context for that
if you can do all this weird time crap
of course you're going to be like a
super dude but yeah I do like this part
they showed up with these soldiers who
are not who are immune to the time stuff
and so that will sort of it's another
wrinkle in that layered sort of system
and then I liked how when you killed
them they stay froze in time they lost
their ability to be out of time and so I
think that like certainly in the demo
setting they are doing a pretty good job
of showcasing some of the cool facets of
the time manipulation in quantum break I
guess remains to be seen how that ends
up playing out quantum break is coming
out april fifth 2016 and presumably the
TV show is going to be right along with
that it's kind of core to the experience
i'd imagine yeah alright well that's
quite a break out of gamescom another
game that we saw right early on that
we've been like not knowing a lot about
scale bounds oh yes yeah rhinos dragons
we saw we saw the reveal or it's like
here's something from kamiya because
they're working on a game for every
system and here's one with dragons
Platinum Games is busy these days well
it was not just dragons that we saw in
the reveal to it was like giant bug
monsters some other cut like it was sort
of cast a net a little wider here in the
gameplay demo of course okay with the
guy with the beat yeah alright yeah
let's talk about this dude real quick
his name is Drew and he's from Earth
he's Dante even it's like just like
Dante from devil may cry yeah well my
mom what's wrong with that Donna table
double micro is awesome he has a sword
goes round cool jacket that people love
the same saw like over-the-top
one-liners that Dante have like he's
totally like a bro you know there's a
chicken kicking butt yeah but I don't
need Dante to point o with beats though
his attitude was definitely something
like circa 2003 video gaming I don't
know about that like it but he does I
mean would what let's talk about the
combat abilities alright because because
I don't think that we all had sort of a
little off-putting reactions to the sort
of cool
yeah I attitude but dragon in terms of
this interrupt interplay between the
dragon and you fighting at the same time
what do you guys think well I think I
mentioned this movie are watching it
that it it kind of feels like it's the
last guardian but not for [ __ ] this
is the last party but your your dinosaur
cat thing is gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] up he's not
Duffy you breathe fire and I tell him to
go destroy something and he does it
doesn't mean your dragon for adults
basically yeah like he flies up he's
just like shooting raining fire down
like I'm really curious how much you
have control over that and how much it's
just like here's an AI constructed it
it's deciding how it's gonna fight stuff
around you but if you have any kind of
control over if you're like they go over
their brief my breathe raining fiery
destruction on everybody like audits
that's pretty cool that's actually
really cool I loved that I loved those
scenes when you know he was just
fighting with the dragon and then this
scene that you're saying now where
another massive monster comes in and
then the dragon in the mosque you just
go head to head you're like climbing up
on top of the monster and stuff if those
things are hot and then you absorb it
apparently he's up that's what he's
doing right now right things you take
their phone turn it into a bunch of
little gems and then you've got the wall
down it's drawing I was like it's like
Skyrim that's orbiting Dragon Soul also
has a huge monster hunter fan like this
is awesome like you're you're a guy
who's taking down big monsters you have
a big monster on your side like this is
a kind of gameplay that I love I think
Monster Hunters an apt comparison
because earlier in that fight we just
saw the conclusion of it there but there
is there was sort of you know having the
dragon work on some armor and then you
attacking but then you like the dragon
getting knocked on its ass and then you
sort of using that like dragon arm power
or whatever they call it to turn into a
more hulking warrior and then there was
like a grapple attack they did in one
point so it seems like these monster
encounters whereas fighting the human
soldiers will just kind of slashing them
up and smashing things which is great
especially for the power fantasy of hey
I get to roll with dragon the monster
fights are the ones where they're going
to be more tactically interesting and
then a mix of different weapons like you
also had the bow and arrow like you're
kind of you're a ranged attack and being
able to switch those up which built very
much more like a devil may cry game that
you have a range of weapons you're able
to access unlike a monster hunter where
you have like here's one weapon you're
going to learn how to use it really well
so like that's the thing that I like
that you have that mix of really
fast action oriented devil may cry we'd
still like some kind of strategic
element and how are you gonna take these
guys down like oh I need to throw a mine
over and that's gonna stagger this
partly the enemy after I shoot it with
bow and arrow and I can do some other
attack on that like that strategy mixed
like that seems like it's gonna be
really interesting all right before we
move on I have two questions about drew
my boy oh he's your boy now my boy I
mean intro voice that's cool uh he so
this is probably prefer the purposes of
the demo but he puts on headphones right
and we all made jokes about that but
like do you think I mean they're
prominently folk featured in his
character design and we are in the day
and age where like he could pull out a
friggin ipod and like like a van in Game
playlist do you think they'll be that
kind of musical integration uh I don't
know maybe we've seen what Final Fantasy
15 has coleman camping gear i think it
would be possible that we see a branded
headset music whatever may be like I
don't know Apple music he's got his
Apple music going we and Sony you know
is a lot into hardware a lot into their
own headphones and peripherals maybe
this is gonna be Microsoft's entry into
that these are gonna be your limited
edition scalebound Microsoft headphones
drag it with your xbox one dragon Beats
or the game that James somehow knows if
you listen to music through the xbox and
the guys hooks on the headphones it
started jamming out yeah you've got your
little super cool surface pro choosing
your playlist and then he puts that on
and you're listening to Taylor Swift and
ripping up some mantises not the other
question is a little more serious about
gameplay is like this is Drew and his
dragon but in the reveal we saw a bunch
of other heroes and a bunch of other
creatures and we learned today that it's
gonna have four player co-op mm-hmm
let's let's get some speculation going
here you're probably gonna play other
characters right I mean I would assume
so unless it's gonna be like a watchdog
situation where you're all the same guy
I'll be terrible just in the same area
can be terrible alright which other
monsters would you want to play as you
want to you want like a Mothra any of
you guys mafra this is what you want to
be dragon why would you want anything
yeah really look this one has like nine
heads why do I Hydra I wanna be 29
headed dragon know how to fight against
him I only give a [ __ ] about this drag
Hydra so like that dragon did it look a
little different like these are all
these are not like your dragons are
looking different though like they have
what a different look to them well
dragons that can't
I are Drake's so maybe there's some
Drake's yeah excellent or if you have
anybody customize those fighters if
there's any customization options that
you have not only for your character but
for the Beast that you have along with
you like ya said recycle you can get
different Jawbone's and probably maybe
put text more arms onto your dragon I
don't know Tiffany you know like like
your headphones they light up in
different colors your Beast is gonna
also light up with different colors
along his lines of power driver dazzle
your own Beast in scalebound that's
slated for holiday 2016 way another one
of the big one which coming out against
Tom 2727 down right did you guys get the
feeling from a lot of the 2016 release
states that it was really going to be
27g that's gonna get to lasers just
Android but you doing the holiday 2016
always means like and you know we're
just pushing it a little bit out like
it's actually January it's still the
holiday of 2016 kind of in a way round
about the winter 2016 it's like what
technically it's still winter til March
sure so it's cool I mean think about it
they have Microsoft has halo coming out
this fall therefore is it coming out
this fall they have rise of the Tomb
Raider coming out this fall I would
imagine they need something in their
fall 2016 holiday slate since all of
their first party stuff is sort of
getting blown out now chairs for again
get here's for us next year yeah people
keep it and so is halo wars 2 that's
true success gonna be packed we're gonna
be talking about halo wars 2 in just a
minute here on the couch folks stick
with us but for now we're gonna take a
look at a game coming up this year Mad
Max new trailer for that one let's take
a look
PEGI 18
you
look behind you a tune after tune of
drifting half-forgotten Terrace you flee
them these past phantoms and the madness
the crawls inside Griffi can help you
venture down to where you dint go
yourself and lay bare your true promise
you have grown into a violent thing a
man of solitude drifting across the
sands
fearing those who make you feel human
you know nothing of me I know what you
seek and I know where you can find it
there's something brewing out there more
boys from gas town are tightening the
noose fierce like
people get in my way people can show you
the lights help you survive people can
bring you the sauce you so desperately
desire war boys have been sighted prep
and most likely for an assault and I
would love a chimp
you wish to know more about yourself
more about the man you've become but
this is a very different world my friend
you tell me son tell you what tell me
why I shouldn't land a slug right
between your eyes
if you hope to survive navigate the
flood escape the past that forever
haunts you and open your eyes in the
darkest hour the believers standing up
other secrets and would behold the true
light I'm looking hard there's nothing
look a king
it's right there in front of you
in a year with a new halo game coming
out you'd expect to see a lot of halo
and microsoft's press conference at
gamecom and we saw a decent amount of
halo I don't know if I would call it a
lot but an interesting tease towards the
end of the show we'll get to that in a
minute first off we're gonna talk about
halo 5 Guardians join me on the couch
it's Alex new house and Mike McCarty hi
guys okay hey hot halo you guys halo
yeah yeah so we're both big Halo fans
yeah uh showed the new map today
Colosseum mm-hmm I mean they do this all
the time when they show a new map and
people like myself get excited about it
but it did it looked like kind of like
one of those a lot of varying sight
lines they're kind of places where you
could see like power weapons like the
sniper rifle coming to play but also a
lot of close quarters which is kind of
always good too but it's also very
vertical map and you know they show them
and playing capture the flag so they
were kind of making use of the jetpack
in the ground pound yeah it's one of
these uh it feels like a close quarters
map and you know watching it because the
players are so focused on the corridors
and the platforms and sort of that
they're kind of place fear you don't I
don't know it's a little tough for me
cuz I don't get to see like the grandeur
of the map you know there's no like halo
arcing up in the distance or man cannons
shooting you across the big map I sort
of I like I'm itching to see some bigger
maps out of halo but we saw a little bit
of those are in war zone demos at e3
this year and so here we're seeing a
close match between some eSports folks
and one of the notable things here and
sort of halo 5s very uh what's the word
I'm searching for concerted push into
eSports they were like huge emphasis on
it is this a spectator mode that's
showing you the silhouettes of all the
guys around yeah and I think this is
huge like with a first person shooter if
you're trying to make a push in the
eSports you desperately need a spectator
mode to make that thing worth it you
know with any sort of a sports event or
even you know let's say DOTA League of
Legends they all have those like over
the top or you know the the sort of most
of that you see everything that's
happening on the field you really need
to have that sort of perspective to know
where you are on the map like who's
around you if you're watching it if
you're if you're trying to you know
follow it and i think the silhouettes an
interesting trick because so much of the
satisfaction I get from playing halo
multiplayer is the mind game of position
and you know i think you're around the
corner are you going to push are you
going to try to grenade and hold off or
you're just going to crouch and wait so
like as a spectator it's not always easy
to have that kind of sense for what's
going on on the flow of the map
especially when you're hopping between
perspectives so getting that sort of at
a glance info to like give you a little
bit more to work with give you a little
bit better understanding what's going on
I think it's a good move they're also
trying to bring a lot of attention to
the eSports mode by ass offering up a
lot of money million-dollar prize pool
for the halo World Championships it's
not quite the biggest prize pool in
eSports not really by a longshot with
the International going on right now but
what do you think I think this sort of
pushed for halo 5 eSports is gonna going
to bear fruit you guys optimistic I'm
optimistic yeah i think you know halo 5
definitely seems like of any halo it
doesn't it seems like it's the most
welded design for eSports I think it'll
you know like you said the prize pool is
a million dollars maybe maybe a little
more I think it's million okay but you
know you have the International which is
like 17 right now this week but I think
it's a good start at least it gets my
hopes up because halo 5 looks great from
what I've seen and what I played so far
and I'm excited to see what that
tournament can do for would you watch
some competitive halo yeah definitely
would you go to a stadium in Seattle to
watch some competitive halo mmm yeah not
yeah that one thing all right so halo 5
Guardians actually not the biggest halo
news to come out of gamescom that honor
goes to the conference ending
announcement reveal of halo wars 2 halo
wars the RTS sort of scion of the Halo
franchise came out in 2009 I lukewarm
reception at best I would have to say
but what do you guys think we did you
have some halo wars fun okay I am so
excited for this is by far my favorite
reveal of Microsoft's gamescom event I
absolutely loved the original Halo Wars
I was that guy who was like you know
that is like I'm you know in a 9 level
games like I loved it really and yet I I
thought it was what you like about it I
thought it was the best example of an
RTS on a console mom that's existed so
far i also just you know I loved that it
was an RTS in the halo University of
something so novel
then when I think it was Bungie was
developing Halo 3 ODST at that point
mm-hmm or just released it and it was
just a really novel way to you know get
something new into the halo formula and
so I just thought that the campaign was
awesome i didn't really play much
multiplayer but the story missions were
really good and it was a nice seeing
other a glimpse in this story and so
that was course developed by ensemble
studios this one the is helmed up by
Creative Assembly better known well you
know known for their Total War series
and you know if anyone's got some RTS
chops it's these guys but in terms of
the RTS on console that's a new new
thing of course worth remembering that
this is for Xbox one and Windows 10 yeah
yeah and it's interesting because like
Alex said I think they did a really
unsubtle did a really good job of you
know mapping the controls to a
controller as opposed to keyboard and
mouse mm-hm it'd only be interesting to
see how someone that has so much
experience with RTS Creative Assembly
will handle it I think they'll do I
think it'll do a good job and I'm
interested to see how they can expand
the scope because halo wars unlike Alex
I didn't like it as much I think I liked
it for about five hours I really like
that it gave us another look at you know
the early days of the human covenant war
because this was a prequel to halo
combat evolved so you get to see a new
side of that but also I think that after
a few hours of playing you kind of see
everything the game has to offer at
least I felt like that so I'm interested
to see how creative assembly might
create a longer lasting experience maybe
because it looks promising i'm i'm
pretty excited it could also be
interesting to see you know with
creative Assembly's work with total war
which has massive you know huge scale
battles what they do with that and
potentially if they you know expand the
scope of the Halo Wars battles could be
super interesting here's hoping also
brutes you guys like to see those hairy
bastards back again a lot of them all
the time oh yeah alright that's coming
out in fall 2016 who knows if it'll land
there or not but that's again coming up
for Xbox one and Windows 10 an
interesting question here I think is is
this the halo experience that people are
going to get on pc microsoft is so much
about halo being this flagship series
this really you know obviously it is a
pillar of their exclusive studio do you
think halo
yours is enough halo on the pc or do you
guys want to see more I'd like to see
more I think it's a good start I mean I
know that sounds like the easy question
but I think it's a good idea to kind of
gauge how much people want because I
think you know that it is a big it's in
demand on PC and everything but I'm
excited to see how they could use this
as a springboard to kind of get into
more and you know there are a few genres
i can think of that would be better
suited for pc than RTS i think it I
think it's a good start as well like
what they have so far on the pc is
Spartan strike and Spartan assault and
then halo 1 and so if they really push
you know start a push into like here's a
fully fledged game here's something that
we know that fans of the Halo series as
a whole will like then I think that's a
good start into something you know
expanding more alright folks let us know
what you think about the halo wars 2
announcement in the comments below one
of the biggest surprises to come out of
gamescom 2015 up next we're going to
take a look at the doom trailer just
released for gamescom special and then
we're back here to talk more microsoft
press conference games stick with us
you
gotta look at home front revolute sorry
guys it's home front the revolution home
from the revolution coming out of games
come with a demo that showed off a lot
of the sort of a glimpse of the
open-world stuff and a sweet motorcycle
here to talk about that game Aaron
Samson and Mike McCarty hi guys how's it
going hey oh it's going good uh pretty
entertaining press conference there were
some some decent games on show nothing
to blow you away but I was personally
interested in homefront the revolution I
kind of like that game a bunch even
though it like ended I don't know
two-thirds of the way to ended way too
early yeah they just kind of got to the
Golden Gate Bridge and they're like hey
we want good job guys yeah the bridge
the city now don't worry about it we'll
talk about it later homefront the
revolution obviously switching coasts
and advancing the timeline a little bit
now you're in Philadelphia now the
Korean People's Army is not invading
they are occupying full-on across the
United States and this demo started
we're getting a look now at the sort of
motorcycle driving in the witch like
here's the question I'm asking how big
is this world that this person is
driving through could you take a left
and a right and drive off into some
direction with this motorcycle or is it
like basically you got to go this way
yeah I was kind of looking through this
footage it seems like at least in this
mission they're channeling and a large
arena it looked like the map did have
boundaries but when I was reading up on
home front the revolution it seems like
they're going more the Far Cry 4 route
you have main missions and then you can
go on the side quests and liberate
strike points essentially and then you
know the map does that reveal and some
of the things that it showed there was
an ammo cache those akp a stronghold so
yeah really channeling that open-world
vibe of like the Far Cry see ya like the
sort of outpost attacks in Far Cry you
know you sort of work your way in and
pick them off and take them down but in
this one it seems like you work your way
in to get a foothold you do that kind of
hacking thing real quick and then a
bunch of new missions open up in the
area allowing you to sort of it says I
think establish a presence because like
guerrilla warfare is what this you know
what this game is all about and that's
always a tricky one with a first person
shooter because you want to be the guy
who's just shooting everyone in the
first person shooter but here it seemed
and you certainly are in the
one but there's also there's crafting
there's hacking seems like there's a
little bit more to in play it's
interesting one of the other things that
we just saw there was also weapon hot
swapping like getting scopes and
attachments on and off of your weapon
yeah I know that Crytek had a little bit
of a hand in this game and I previously
saw that in their war face games so I
wonder if I think I crisis had it a
little bit too yeah yeah totally I think
that they you know that was watching our
e3 demo from 2014 actually they're
saying you know it's in our DNA a little
bit of course we're gonna do this weapon
customization stuff so yeah that was
definitely on display here with the yep
I'm just gonna like put on a new scope
I've got an ID in my pocket that was in
modern warfare 3 if I recall correctly
as well that was like a big driving
force with modern warfare 3 2 said look
you can do this on the go that was a
huge selling point I guess yeah that
would be really cool if this ends up in
their multiplayer they just hinted at
their multiplayer and they said
something about you being able to team
up with your friends and I like in
faction or crew which hopefully is more
than just you friending up with somebody
at like I hope that there's a little bit
more of a story there are you thinking
more of something like a long line of
the division maybe where you've got you
know sort of multiple teams vying for a
same objective although I guess that
would really make sense narrative Lee in
homefront in the wood cuz you basically
got to side maybe more Lions and the
lack of us where you get status updates
that your friend is not off the face of
a raccoon or build a fence or got
dysentery that was like the best
facebook integration that any game has
ever had but Aaron the multiplayer is
something that you and I enjoy quite a
bit in home front and what was the
defining thing there that really sort of
separated it was you you earn these
battle points through your actions and
then there's like a pretty broad array
of drones you can bring to bear yeah the
drone warfare was quite good and that's
one of the things that actually showed
here in the trailer was the guy driving
the RC car bomb all that stuff made it
into multiplayer there were aerial
drones and ground drones and it was cool
because it you know it extended your
life in the game you know instead of
just running in with your guns blazing
you could actually set up a good
strategic moves and your drone in first
and have it messed things up there also
like this single player had some really
large drones that more main characters
in the game but yeah the
the drone aspect I think that came from
frontlines fuels of war that's where the
mechanics came from for that he not only
that but they also had a lot of
personality which I like to the
personality said like the drones or just
in general like in general you've got
that beat up revolution so the drones
had personality and then the I think the
weapons especially in this demo we saw
were a little bit more beat up and you
know you have a better sense of time in
place of a battle and I posted generic
mix older to you yeah and I think that
was one of the strengths of the
homefront series right is setting the
mood setting a time in place and
certainly the trailer they showed at
Gamescom with that little kid giving the
like forced speech in for you know
propaganda speech in front of the
assembled army generals and whatnot
there it looks like they're going to be
leaning even more into this this sort of
this setting Mike this is a tricky
setting though because you're basically
playing as a terrorist in your own
country yeah because in the first game
being on the west coast it was it was
kind of unsettling because you are
rising up against these you know these
governing forces that have since taken
over there's a plague that comes into
play somewhere before the storyline the
first one and obviously now they're
going to the east coast which is
exciting for me because that was always
a cool setting to me I think that's
something the last of us also kind of
satisfied that futuristic dystopian in
the last of us case it was
post-apocalyptic but it's kind of cool
to see the America we know in a
different setting and now that they're
on the East Coast I'm excited because my
home turf but it'll be cool to see how
they handle that especially because like
Aaron said for multiplayer in single
player you know they were kind of going
off frontline their work on frontline
fuel of war and it'll be kind of cool to
see how they iterate since the you know
the original game has got maybe not aged
so well I'm curious to see how they do
with the sequel and what new like sort
of gut-wrenching stunts they pull hiding
in a mass grave I don't think I've ever
done that in any other video game except
for homefront that's homefront the
revolution coming out 2016 I think is
the general time period so we'll see how
that shapes up in the coming months
another big announcement at Gamescom
well not an announcement but we saw a
little bit more finally of crackdown 3
the long-awaited third game in
crackdown trilogy which made such a
splash on xbox 360 you guys feel about
crackdown jumping on buildings grabbing
the herbs dude superhero stuff you like
it yeah I had a lot of fun with the
first crack down I remember I think
after like call duty to it was one of
the first xbox 360 games I played I
really like the you know you know the
action based experience where you know
in order to gain agility you have to get
these coins and that was my favorite
part of the game was being able to jump
these you know 20-story skyscrapers in
one jump and you know improving your
vehicle skills it was just fun all
around toward the end the game you're
really overpowered and then the fact
that they're calling it 100%
destructible environments we'll see ya
what I was under the old claim yeah
because I just imagine the entire city
being leveled they showed them a
skyscraper just kind of falling and
creating this domino effect which
potentially looks cool but I'm curious
because this was a pre-alpha footage i'm
curious how that will end up in the
final build I mean if I recall right
previous crackdown games did have some
trouble with the physics engine when
there was too much stuff going on
on-screen at once but it's a really good
it's really good concept I really love
the red faction series like red faction
guerilla in any game that channels that
level of destruction is is great in my
book and we're seeing obviously this is
pre alpha so it doesn't you know the
detail on textures and stuff isn't that
super but like I'm okay with that like
if if they're gonna actually accomplish
this kind of destructibility like I
don't need to go up and look and see
like realistic concrete picture staring
back at me like crackdown has always had
this kind of like vaguely stylized
cartoonish kind of look to it and I
think if they lean into that maybe they
can save some processing power on
textures and stuff obviously I'm a
technical so technically exact I
definitely understand how all this works
no but you know it's like it's
interesting to see that kind of ambition
because I think destructibility is like
this is one of the sort of new frontiers
that like graphically and engine wise we
still there's still a lot of room to
push it also does beg the question if
everything is destructible you know
who's gonna be the first guy to try and
destroy the entire map oh yeah is that
gonna happen definitely right away we
you're going to have to have I think you
know because they're also talking about
a multiplayer they mentioned it
multiplayer beta like
Xbox one folks are internet first access
to that in summer 2016 so you know
multiplayer that kind of destruction
well you just have a new match and it's
all back but how does that destruction
play into single player is there even a
single player proper campaign i don't
know like it could just be some kind of
multiplayer shared hero space where we
all just romping around fighting over
orbs and again going back to a red
faction they did have a good multi
player in that game where you can do fun
things like you jump on the roof of a
building somebody to be running below
you and you just pop the roof open and
then throw a grenade in it was that
really cool idea if you're not safe
anywhere in anything oh yeah and the
fact that it's you know your superhuman
cyborg police officers kind of adds even
more weight to the fact that you might
be able to stride literally anything and
that if you get to use that effectively
against other human players that'll be
pretty awesome to see yeah i think that
dropping a building on someone could be
pretty delightful probably hurts /
effective all right we'll be looking for
more on crackdown 3 as gamescom
continues of course we're going to be
here all week with gamescom coverage
coming from germany and come at you from
our offices here in san francisco next
up we have a trailer for naruto and then
we're coming back to talk about one of
the bigger demos of the microsoft's
gamescom press conference rise of the
Tomb Raider
shut up me
yo Margaret a sticky little Cheney mama
you mock me 50 I'll get it I usually
yokai taking Jim be well done you no
good to us
aakhri restaura luego
madam snow futuna
touch the walkthrough yaar na kaya mo
Chiu needles last level [ __ ]
see
ok
ah
[ __ ]
let's go
we got to see lara croft in action in
rise of the Tomb Raider and the two
women sitting on the couch here it got
to see even more so we they are the ones
we want to talk to about rise of the
Tomb Raider alexa ray corriea Mary Kish
thanks for coming on set yeah and rise
of the tomb raider lara croft his back
and like super murderous not that she
wasn't murderers and rot in Tomb Raider
come on I mean that's what she does yeah
we were I don't know we were we left the
demo we were sitting in the car in
silence and then Mary turns to me and
just says this is the most metal gear
we've ever seen Laura Croft metal gear
she straight up broke a bottle and
stabbed two dudes through it with it
yeah Metal Gear was more about how you
have way more player choice you can
actually decide how you want to attack
us a given situation something that they
didn't show in that footage that we got
to see I thought was really amazing is
that you can take stuff from the
environment like mushrooms and you can
make a bomb with it you can kill some
dude adhere the bomb to his chest throw
them out there so that somebody else
will inevitably find the body be like oh
my god there's dead guy over here run
over to it the bomb goes off a poison
cloud comes over and kills that guy to
trap corpses it's great it's so great
it's like another level of how you want
to do it so obviously yeah you could go
in there with a gun which is how I did a
lot of it last two Raider not always
kind of got a little bored with doing
that I don't always want to go in guns
blazing I this tomb raider is giving us
the opportunity to be really sneaky it
gives you opportunity to attack things
for different angles and i were directly
in the face was right that's how I
played tomb raider number one yeah
that's that's how i did it and i
remember them saying to us also that you
might remember that when you were able
to unlock character skills by the time
the game was done everyone had all the
same skills unlocked yes it was like you
did it but really all they were doing
was they were preventing you from having
all that stuff at once but by the end of
the game we all had the same Laura yeah
nothing was different well in this one
Lara's skill tree divides much wider and
the amount of stuff that you will obtain
throughout the game will not give the
ability to have everything yeah now you
can actually customize your your
RF for the one you want they were
telling us that you could play the whole
game and not unlock everything like they
have the skills are a little bit
different there's more exploration focus
skills and then we're combat focus
skills and you could choose to either I
guess focus on may be upgrading her
climbing ax or upgrading you know some
her you there's a skill where you can
learn how to read glyphs and stuff so
you get that sort of our key
archaeological element to it so you can
either focus on one of the other and by
the time you're done like you'll have
like your Laura may be different from
like someone else's Laura cuz you
focused on this one thing or you maxed
out this one thing I think it sounds
really cool and certainly the lower we
saw in this demo you know was sort of
more the pugilistic more violent Laura
but this is also like you know if you're
demoing something at Gamescom you're not
going to show oh my god I've been
running around this big open area for
like 30 minutes find all these little
things which was one of my favorite
parts of Tomb Raider and of course
that's going to be in rise of the Tomb
Raider as well let's talk a little bit
about that exploration did you see a
little bit more of that during the demo
that you saw we did we actually got a
look at the prophets tomb which is one
of the first tombs in the game big tombs
are back like big physics-based puzzle
late in tombs and we spend I think it
was maybe like 20 or so minutes in it
and there's a lot of they've sort of
built the tutorial into the environment
so it'll give you like a small situation
like you need to learn to flutter room
to get Laura to a higher platform and
they present it to you in like little
bit so by the time you're towards the
end of the tomb and things are more
difficult you sort of know oh like I
look four walls that look like this and
then I can use this and it was just like
it's beautiful I hope those tools in
your arsenal to create something that's
more complex in the way that like many
good sort of puzzle solving kind of
situations are and it's great to hear
that yeah those tombs are big I think
that's been one of the bigger focuses
certainly of their PR campaign for rise
of the Tomb Raider is yeah yeah guys are
tombs are back in a big way members I
think we all remember the disappointment
of walking into a secret cave and having
it say optional tomb nobody wants an
optional to I'm a tomb raider and they
said that was a huge part that they
wanted to fix in this one so yeah tombs
are not really optional anymore this is
about this is
about exploration and finding out and
discovery because of the next-gen they
can make the tombs bigger I believe
they've claimed that there are three
times they can make three times the size
and with that as you're saying Chris
more secrets so tomb raiders known for
these secrets and the revamped they kind
of changed the word secret literally
you'd find this little shiny object in
tomb Raider's right and it would say you
found a secret I'd be like cool I don't
know what that is but it's a secret in
this one and the revamped Laura they've
been doing a GPS has been out of them
and just like little artifacts is
another one that you can find and
they've done that for this one as well
so you will find a sneaky little
artifacts hidden without the game and I
believe they're going to bring back GPS
and other other secrets within the area
so there's more to discover than than
just finding out what's in said tomb
there's always hidden pieces along the
way yeah and Laura's not going into that
Laura's not fighting for survival
anymore so she's sort of proactively
running into this adventure and throwing
herself in danger because she's I
believe the story this time is she's
following her father's research and
looking for these secrets in these two
connected myths which I've explained in
a lovely a primer on gamespot com um and
it's and you you get the sense that
she's not like you're not trying to
fight people off anymore you're actively
like running in and I think that sort of
proactivity and that that it makes her
very action focus like you can see her
becoming this is the bottle part yeah
like she's becoming becoming the tomb
raider yeah I know that sounds cheesy
and that's obviously like the name of
the game but I think from what we saw
you really you really see it and you're
really feeling it that she's growing and
she's maturing and she's becoming this
like savvy super-smart archaeologists
and like super physical prowess badass
lady she's coming into her own I think
there was something to be said about the
story lacking a little bit in the first
game I am a huge fan of the series of
stories are never you know huge parts
that like no like anyone ever believed
that Laura did backflips all the time
every time she jumped and killed the
Tyrannosaurus wix with two pistols yeah
she's cool but ladies this
new this new way that they've taken
laura is very realistic they want you to
feel like she's a real human being that
has feelings and emotions and she she
goes through some [ __ ] and sometimes she
gets stabbed through the belly and that
hurts and it likes changes the way she
can play the game but the story in the
first game got a little obscure you
didn't really know why she was doing
this or why she was even exploring
anything at all because she was barely
surviving she was like struggling to
live just wants to get off that crazy
hell yeah place was messed up and in
this one it's not so much that she's
trying to survive she's putting herself
in dangerous scenarios because she wants
to know what's going on she's starting
to realize that she's a very unique
person she has all these unique
capabilities where she can take down
t-rexes with pistols and it's a mistake
for her to not put herself in danger
because she's one of a kind yeah I think
that they're selling that character a
lot better in this one she's just a very
unique person and she's super badass and
she will cut you action hero Lara Croft
rise of the Tomb Raider coming out this
year November 13th no that's Europe we
are getting it November tense even
better sorry Europe all right Alexa Mary
thank you so much if you guys want to
know more about rise of the Tomb Raider
as election Alexa mentioned she's got a
big article about Laura up on the site
as well as a couple other videos you
delve right into it and see a lot more
of what's in store for rise of the Tomb
Raider all right we are coming back with
a little bit more are we about done here
yeah alright gamescom show so like let's
like get some closing thoughts on
microsoft's press conference they kicked
it off for gamescom and you know we're
going to be seeing sort of more out of
different companies as the week
progresses is there anything you're
looking forward to anything you thought
that like stood out for you from today
or disappointed you or anything well
there is no viva pinata so no whatever
games comes over for me your hopes of
viva pinata dashed come on where replay
just came out mash but I want another
one just came out they gotta like I want
to go through it pinata banging
simulator I'm sure that you will get
your pinata breeding situation all
sorted out sometime in your lifetime
Alexa thank you
all right folks that's our special
episode here from the lobby and taking a
look at microsoft's gamescom press
current conference we're gonna be having
gamescom awesomeness all week so be sure
to stick with us thanks for watching
you